Jaclyn has dark brown hair show is team  Judi soupy and her favorite color is  pink and red rat her bike dance free and  she loves a tumble  it's the first time that I've got to  watch jacqueline compete in person and  she did not disappoint me I could tell  she had a lot of personality on skype  but seeing her on stage today was so  impressive here we go judges here we go  with the outfit of choice jungle wear  in outfit-of-choice jungle where the  judges want personality they want to see  someone come out on stage hit all the  marks and to have that competitive  aspect of life  first of all they learned the most  important thing in Nets life is a  competition that's in jobs and sports  and everything no one's a loser at  Bayley's patches and no one should be a  loser in life